et bien bonjour comment allez vous moi
ça va extrêmement bien aujourd'hui on
tourne pas dans mon studio on est dans
le studio de ladrière aujourd'hui c'est
différent
tu vas partir sa grâce à l'arrière donc
adrien et maquilleurs prothésiste si
vous n'aviez pas de deviner son métier
c'est créer des costumes et des
maquillages
en fait c'est de faire des choses qu'on
n'aura pas besoin de faire en effets
spéciaux qui vont du coup paraître plus
réel plus naturel qui vont bien rendre
devant la caméra qu'est ce qu'on fout là
me demanderez vous voyez ça ça c'est
totalement un buste de moi écouter je
suis venu c'est pierre trouplin je suis
venu il y à un mois ici pour faire un
moulage de mon visage c'était le pire
moment de ma vie puisque finalement
j'avais du plâtre sur la gueule pendant
40 minutes et je pouvais respirer
uniquement à l'aide d'une sorte de
petite paille
il faut vraiment pas être claustrophobe
je vous assure c'était une belle époque
psychologique j'ai pu méditer sur moi
même et faire le bilan de ma vie c'était
agréable
le résultat c'est qu'on a un buste de
moi même pourquoi on abuse de moi même
parce que adrien a pu travailler sur ce
bus pour me faire des prothèses qui vont
modifier mon visage va se faire passer
pour une fouille chaîne de télé une
fausse émission on va aller dans la rue
demander aux gens ce qu'ils pensent de
moi même alors que je serai devant le
savez hyper intéressant d'avoir l'avis
des gens sans filtre avec une honnêteté
extrême puisqu'il pense pas que je suis
devant eux étant donné que je suis sous
un déguisement de présentateurs télé je
me retrouvais avec ses voeux avec des
lunettes avec tous mes traits de visage
déformé ça va être un grand moment
c'est parti pour 4 5 heures de
maquillage on y va
[Musique]
bienvenue sur youtube tv mec je me
reconnais pas ma gueule ça me stresse de
ouf j'ai une balle calvitie ou a pas ce
mytho tu me fais pas des mecs
j'étais pas dans ces bars à avoir 50 ans
mais bon on va maintenant sortir
demander aux gens ce qu'ils pensent de
youtube et de faire fuir le monde moi on
verra enfin la vie des gens le vrai à
vis des gens et c'est parti on suit
henry je vais changer ma démarche charge
la démarche est obligé de changer madame
harel bonjour les jeunes vous avez deux
minutes pour la télé on fait une petite
émission sur ce que pensent les gens des
gros youtuber vous en connaissez vous en
regardez qui vous suivez sur youtube mr
jean des sables en frites hugo tout seul
je crois domingo jour du grenier lors du
grenier hockey lors du grenier et toi
[Musique]
alors tout le monde est joueur du
grenier yak luc existe un d'accord on a
compris je vous vois partir attention
vous êtes en train de fuir
j'ai droit à deux questions oh la vache
elle m'a eu à les fortes qui te fait
rire dix mois on veut des noms ici dans
cette rubrique
non alors franchement moi je suis fan de
ludovic ça c'est un mec mais il fait je
connais il fait comme moi en mieux greg
guilloteau et ses caméras cachées
s'éprend qu'elles sont excellentes des
américains ok comme qui logan paul hamon
dire qu'est ce tu portes de cyprien
franchement cyprien j'aime bien
il y fait des bonds tuto il fait il fait
tout il fait des tutos qu à des tutos
cyprien norman tout ça non vous avez un
masque un hamas j'ai des problèmes de
peau avant scène il faisait du tout mais
je crois oui il avait fait un truc pour
faire un calendrier en bois tu l'avais
vue ouais c'est ça je crois que c'est ça
est-ce que je suis pris un thème path
non ce trop ça fait trop longtemps et
vieillot après un peu beaucoup c'est
toujours un peu pas tu préfères cyprien
ou norman non je préfère cyprien quand
même
rien ouais ouais norman en fait c'est un
peu il est pas très beau en plus la whey
au calme pas très beau moi je préfère
norman norman à cyprien ouais ouais je
peux faire mais après moi je regarde pas
trop les trucs comme ça je regarde plus
les cover et tout ça à t dans la musique
est ce que tu peux nous chanter un truc
arthur neobe
et
on m'a dit et toi tu rigoles toi vite à
chat au point d'une mais ça va pas là
haut est le meilleur le meilleur c'est
loupé mr du groupe et mystères vais
aller voir leur spectacle jeunes gens
mus bas alors y'a quoi y'a squeeze aussi
tu connais excusez je suis beau phone
immature ouais c'est ça c'est assez
chiant je suis d'accord ims est immature
un peu ça si bas elles sont donc ces
vidéos si elle se rendre c'est chiant
c'est long et avec sa tête un peu et
exaspère lui à sa joie et exaspère
complètement vous savez il ya très peu
de gens en france qui ont 10 millions
d'abonnés
le prochain s'appelle squeeze et on
prend un peu la vie des gens vis-à-vis
de ce qu'ils en pensent
mais bon tu m'as dit que c'était un peu
un conte donc si tu l'as dit on a les
images toute façon je suis personne pour
juger moi je mets tu peux il n'y a pas
de problème dit que c'est tu peux dire
que c'est un petit [ __ ] ya personne
va te frapper ici parce que ça va se
manger
il y en a qui m'ont dit que c'était un
peu un gamin quand même mais c'est drôle
je sais que tu ressembles aaa au méchant
dans star wars cette honte l'a déjà dit
je n'ai pas vu mais merci je prends ça
comme un compliment tu peux me mets un
sabre-laser voir qu'est ce que tu penses
de squeeze secousse à ce que vous ou moi
que déçu ces derniers temps parce que il
fait des clips et tout laisse tomber et
il chante comme une merde même avec
lotus en marche pas et à notre étude
c'est pour une vidéo sur la chaîne
youtube de squeeze puisque c'est moi non
mais ça y'a moyen tu as vu la gueule que
j'ai quand même ok si je vous dis que je
suis squeeze vous me croyez je parle
comme voilà quoi alors n'y a pas mille
personnes qui parlent de gens je chante
comme plein de gens j'ai plein de trucs
comme [ __ ] mais elle est incroyable
yakhi dotia squeeze ouais je le connais
c'est en pense quoi
regardons il a fait c'est ça c'est lui
tu vas me questionner vas-y résille asie
je le vois tout est question
nom prénom le guerchin bref florange à
27 janvier 96 à vitry-sur-seine gagner
moi parle un peu moins dit des fois dans
tes vidéos parce qu'on comprend pas tout
mais sinon c'est bien j'aime bien ok
quoi d'autre vas-y j'écoute chu vas-y
fait progresser les données par mois
pleins de conseils
ah ça c'est un bon conseil ça et que toi
tu continues des vidéos super
intéressante et patrick trop longue
[Musique]
fin du test les amis j'en peux plus de
cette gueule de merde pourquoi je parle
encore dans ce micro en bordel et un
deuxième sur la caméra les amis c'est un
exercice difficile je vais pas vous
mentir on a fait des rencontres au maroc
il ya même eu des gens qui voulaient pas
être dans la vidéo mais qui on a pu
échanger c'est hyper intéressant dans
l'ensemble c'est pas mauvais les gens
aiment bien les vidéos donc c'est
plaisant pour moi même si certaines
personnes qui fait pas trop les vidéos
c'était marrant plus on a vu vraiment la
vie des gens de ces purs et durs sur les
différents youtuber et tous étaient trop
intéressant merci vous regarde la vidéo
n'était pas là mais c'est plus simple
comme d'habitude
moi j'ai envie de m'arracher la tour
j'en peux plus aux frères j'ai une
gueule c'est encore pire qu'avant blazy
je veux récupérer ma calvitie plus tard
j'ai honte
[Musique]
ça